he went in and he did such a great job
and he
he was throwing his hands up in the air
and um just so excited and just had all
these little
you know cute five-year-old emotions
just pouring out of him
and it was just such a proud moment for
me as a mom um
and then after i heard it back i was
like he's pretty good
you know i i know he can he's got a
little a nice little voice on him but
i was i was very uh he impressed even me
so when i get down on
[Music]
i feel like people are kind of ready for
christmas um
you know even even earlier um this month
you know you would hear stories about
people um
like decorating their houses for
christmas already because they just
need some joy so we just thought i
thought why not
it's three months till christmas um give
plenty of people time to get in the mood
uh super fans can can get the album now
and start celebrating early and then
um hopefully we'll just we'll just
trickle in
you know and and help be the the
soundtrack to
a bright spot in the year now more than
ever
we all need to focus on what christmas
is about rely
more on our family and even though it
has been a tough year
sometimes i feel like the greatest
realizations
can come in the worst times or in the
most stressful times and it makes you
more thankful for the things that you do
have
when we went in i was just like let's
just see what happens we were riding
over zoom which is
not ideal um because you can't
there's there's even if it's just a half
a second there's like a delay so if
somebody's playing something you can't
sing along with it you don't really know
how it's going to turn out
and you know we just we gave it what we
had
[Music]
it still at the end of the the night was
a celebration of
of us and of country music and of even
though it was last year that we were
celebrating
um the the year that we've had um so it
i'm glad that they went ahead and you
know pushed through and had it anyway
um and and i i'm not sure what the other
award shows are going to look like
either but you know we'll figure it out
and
i got to see a couple people like
backstage in the in the halls even
though they were
we were waving at each other from six
feet apart
but it was just nice to kind of have
something that was
somewhat normal
you